I keep thinking that there's gonna be
like an action that's not horse I'll do
one for you okay action
I'm Jason love I'm a sexual artist
hi I'm Angela white and I am an adult
performer producer and director
I'm Kendra Sunderland and I am here with
Tori black and we're gonna answer the
questions about foreign that you are too
scared to ask if you could do a xxx
parody what would it be and who would
you play I wanna be a little mermaid
oh my god that you know because they
asked me to do the little sperm aid I
really like watching a law-and-order so
I would do a LAN Order SVU just so I
could be ice tea if I could be ice tea I
could just bust it when people are like
vodka and be like drop your dick what's
your favorite scene you've done I
recently did a scene with him and well
Ferrara my vixen scene with Manuel
Ferrara mmm good pic I was just about to
say that was my favorite scene teen I
did what I can well you just talked
sturdy so much that I'm like any does it
in French too does your family know what
you do for a living mine do and they
don't care my family does know what I do
I've been very open and honest with my
family from the very beginning my family
do mom and dad mom dad and daughter I
got caught doing a lecture on my school
library so I'm known as library girl and
that's how I got into it so all my
family saw in the news that I was
playing with myself in the school
librarian that I got arrested for it
what's your daughter say I had to bring
that down to a complete verbal science
skip the birds and the bees let's talk
about porn do female porn stars actually
reach climax is a guy asking this do
they actually reach climax yeah some do
some don't it's just like at home some
fake it and some don't I try to every
time yeah I try to I'm like I'm gonna
ride your face until I bust in that for
me always but how do you know they're
not faking even it's the question you
cannot fake the body movements
that means when a scene is over directed
and they tell you come right now you're
so hyper aware of yourself that it's
hard to get lost enough to orgasm you
cannot fake science science liquids
you can't fake it do you have a
satisfying sex life outside of work yeah
I definitely think at home sex is way
better at home you can just go to town
over in the corner yeah guitar and go
lay down and catch your Britain and get
back in you know when your work is like
rabbits have you ever fallen for a
co-star I wouldn't say falling I've had
like a crush yes it had yes
who are your crushes oh I like fell for
them sexually and then couldn't wait to
have sex with them again but as far as
emotionally I actively turn off that
option when you have that kind of
intimate connection with somebody and
not to just break it all right you get
butterflies in their dick to me don't so
cosy if it's fun on a camera you imagine
where there's gonna be great when
there's no camera the size matter
exactly like I can't really answer that
question size does not matter because
what good is a big dick if you don't
know having emotional ocean my problem
is like actually going to defecate in my
dick falling in the water if people
think bigger is always better but like I
personally don't like huge huge stakes I
don't go see guys with little little
penises like if they were working it
right they killing it and some girls
tell me it's too big if I feel like a
little remnant like oh I'm a little sore
that's kind of playful it's kind of fun
but if I'm walking around like it really
isn't about size it's about how you
connect with the process yeah you can
have a little one or you can have mine
it doesn't matter as long as you watch
them you're gonna win trust me what's
your best sex advice for non porn stars
I like this question honesty is probably
the best thing ever listening to like
the body language not necessarily what
people say verbally because people I
like you're doing a great job line
right exactly if they're making good
faces or good movements that seem
genuine keep doing that if you really
want to get crazy with your girlfriend
chances are just sticking your finger
right in her butt and not saying
anything prior is not gonna go over very
well
so probably be like hey I want to put my
finger in your butt
people always say we have the best jobs
in the world a job is a job next what is
what it's work I say it like this
there's some days I shouldn't get paid
and there's other days I should get paid
double you know I feel like our industry
gets a really bad rap because people
think that we're nasty but we're nasty
in all the right ways and not in the
wrong ways so actually most people in
life are backwards they're not as nasty
and freaky as they should be so it's
like you're the wrong nasty nor the
right now see is a bit like us
[Music]